So we've determined that we want to
figure out which set of parameters
provide the best predictions for our
output variable, but how can we do that?
We'll use an algorithm
called gradient descent.
First, we need to define
some cost function
which we'll call J of big theta.
I'm going to use big theta here to
represent our entire set of theta's and
I'll use this notation throughout
the rest of this lesson.
The cost function is meant to
provide a measure of how well our
current set of thetas does at
modeling the observed data.
So we want to minimize
the cost functions value.
As we discussed just a moment ago,
when we're doing linear regression,
our cost function J of theta can simply
measure the sum of the squares of
the differences between our
predicted and observed values.